when you're different sometimes
you feel like a mistake but
but you make her feel like she's not a
mistake at all
[Music]
it's pride month and what better way to
celebrate the queerest time of year than
celebrating the courage and authenticity
of celebrities who have come out and
showed the world their true selves
you know what it never was
that's serious it was never that stupid
to kick things off stranger things Star
Noah schnapp came out as gay at the
beginning of the year revealing his
sexuality in a cheeky Tick Tock with the
caption I guess some more similar to
will than I thought
yes Noah is referring to his stranger
things character will Byers who is also
gay the young star went on to say when I
finally told my friends and family I was
gay after being scared in the closet for
18 years and all they said was we know
[Music]
awesome man
Bella Ramsey has taken the World by
storm for her breakout role as Ellie and
The Last of Us the actor came out as
gender fluid while chatting with the New
York Times and in a recent interview
with British Vogue they explained their
thoughts on pronouns stating I had a lot
of anxiety around pronouns when the last
of us first came out I was like everyone
just call me she because I look like a
she to you so it's fine but now I'm able
to vocalize it more being called they is
the most truthful thing for me that's
who I am the most
but when you're born with that
there's absolutely nothing you can do
about it
nothing
and please understand I tried comedian
Monique came out in a pretty big way
during her Netflix special my name is
Monique she took the time to tell the
crowd how she struggled to come out as
bisexual in fear her grandma would
reject her
because I told her
my secret thoughts
she would have left thinking
that she failed
such a powerful special another star who
came out this year as bisexual Alice and
Brie who broke the internet when she
casually came out during a buzzfeed
thirst tweets video listen I am bisexual
for a reason and that reason is strictly
to be used in a threesome by Dave Franco
and Alison Brie
that's also why I'm bisexual that's
right Allison Brie is bisexual and not
only that she has the support of her
partner Dave who chimed in with some
positive encouragement you've been
waiting for this tweet from someone who
you don't know who they are what they
look like
there's been so many incredible Stars
who've come out this year and joined the
lgbtq plus Community from Alexander
Lincoln Richard Armitage Chloe vich
Curtis Hamilton and the list goes on and
on but one star who reminded us that
sexuality doesn't always need a label is
Diplo when the DJ appeared on Emily
radakowski's podcast he opened up about
his past same-sex sexual experiences you
said you would there's somebody that
would be your boyfriend there's a couple
guys I'd like would like be like this
might be
I'm sure if I got a from a guy
before you you're sure that's happened
yeah and you you just don't remember I
mean you're not being you're saying
you're not committing to it but you're
saying you're sure it happened yeah
for sure getting a is not that
gay
I think